hello so uh welcome to the the next
section of cs229 so what we're going to
talk about in the next series of about
four lectures is the start of
unsupervised and kind of less supervised
learning and I'll make that concrete and
kind of the plan is is what you're going
to see is you're going to see a bunch of
things that look like
um various different ways of dealing
with this fundamental problem of what do
we do when we don't have labels right so
we're first going to look at an
algorithm called k-means and then we're
going to look at this algorithm called
GMM this gaussian mixture model those
will both happen today and we'll try and
put those algorithms on kind of solid
footing in the maximum likelihood
framework okay we'll then see a couple
of more algorithms that have to do with
this unsupervised way of viewing the
world one of them you're going to use in
your homework called ICA it's actually
the reason I teach it it's kind of a fun
algorithm it's a weird bit of setup but
it's probably people's favorite homework
problems when we look through the kind
of feedback it's a fun problem if you
remember the cocktail problem from the
first day where you have people talk
talking in a party you have microphones
scattered around the edge and you want
to know who said what you want to do
what's called sometimes Source
separation and understand the sources so
we'll we'll do that in the in the ICA
section
and then we'll talk about a a more
advanced topic called weak supervision
weak supervision is industrially used to
create large training sets for big deep
learning models which you've just come
out of that but these are labels that
are lower quality than the traditional
supervised labels and then finally we'll
talk about self-supervised learning
which is really exciting and is one of
the big Revolutions in machine learning
where we train on something simple like
predicting the next word and if we train
on enough data we can use it for all
these other sometimes called Downstream
tasks okay so that's kind of the program
for the next four or five lectures and
today we're going to start with with
those Basics okay so we're going to
start with the basics is unsupervised
and work our way up to pretty modern
stuff and I will say historically I
would say five years ago I kind of
didn't like teaching unsupervised
because it felt kind of squishy and
weird to be honest with you it didn't
have the beautiful Theory or maybe even
10 years ago didn't have the beautiful
theory of supervised learning where you
could say like this is the right model
and we go find it in a lot of cases but
that's been where almost all the
research activity not only in my group
but kind of from AI over the last three
or four years has been in this
unsupervised realm so we'll start with
some of the classics and get our way to
something really really exciting
so
the classic and probably an algorithm
you already know or probably you can
guess kind of how it works is this
algorithm called k-means all right and
then we'll get to these other ones but
this is the one we're going to start
with first so what's the difference so
in the supervised setting right we get
points and the key issue is that the
points come with labels you have labeled
these plus and these minus as we were
doing and we would draw a line or a
boundary in between them that was the
way we formalized a wide variety of
learning tasks okay right and the point
is is those pluses and minuses those are
labels right
and unsupervised started in this setting
I give you the points but I don't tell
you any labels underneath the covers
okay now there are many things on the
spectrum between I give you the labels
perfectly to I don't show you any
information about the labels and I just
show you the data points we're going to
talk about that Spectrum but now we're
going to start in the cleanest setting
and unsupervised where we just see those
points okay
now
the the thing that you should calibrate
here is like what can we expect as an
answer so in the supervised setting as I
said it was super clear what we wanted
like we could talk about what this line
is and we can go deeper and deeper into
like why that's the right line right
that's the right separating hyperplane
and the unsupervised case it's
necessarily squishing we'll talk about
the ways in which it's squishy and what
I mean by that is it's harder in some
sense so unsupervised learning is harder
and what I really mean by that
than supervised
what I really mean by that is we have to
allow stronger assumptions
okay stronger assumptions
right so one of the things that kind of
passed by you without thinking about it
too much in the supervised setting is
you're like there's just some data and
there exist a separator there exists
some class
that's pretty weak for what we had to
assume about the data
for unsupervised we're going to have to
assume there's some kind of latent or
hidden structure and a lot of the
conversation is hey if that structure is
there can I provably recover it that's
the kind of thing that we're going to do
and we're going to trade off kind of
assuming more about our data
and trying to find it robustly okay and
now
compared to supervise we're also going
to accept weaker guarantees
okay so weaker guarantees
so in supervised learning in many cases
that we cared about
I think your guarantees we would say
like we got exactly the right answer
right this was the right model we could
say you know there were some Theta star
out there that was just the right thing
we were looking at as we'll see and I'll
come I'll show some examples in a second
in this unsupervised world it's not
super clear uh you know what the right
answer should be all the time if I just
show you this picture and say how many
clusters are there some of you say well
there's two clusters
somebody said well why aren't there six
there's six points why isn't each one in
its own cluster
and if we'll see in some examples it's
not really clear what there is we have
to make some assumption or do some
modeling to understand and kind of kind
of get to the bottom of our data okay
and so that's what I mean by weaker
guarantees and stronger assumptions and
we'll see those mathematically but just
keep them in the back of your head we're
going to be more comfortable saying like
what if our data are generated this way
that's going to be a stronger assumption
and then we're going to say you know we
can't recover something that's pretty
good some of the time
all right this is less jarring to you
than it was like historically honestly
because historically we would teach the
first part of supervised Learning
Without things like neural Nets and all
the rest and neural Nets you kind of got
comfortable with the fact that like hey
maybe it's Computing something useful
maybe it's not we don't know we just run
it for long enough okay this used to be
a little bit more disturbing okay so if
you look at the literature you'll you'll
see that in it so let's start with our
with our first version of this
all right so what we're going to be
doing is we're going to be given some
data oops it's not very doesn't look
very nice this is our given data okay
given
and we have some points and this is
basically me just introducing notation
and copying
what we had before all right we're also
here as I mentioned that stronger
structure we're going to also be given a
parameter which says how many clusters
we think there are
so the game is going to be here I'm
going to write down you know K is equal
to 2 and our goal is that what we want
to do here is find a good clustering
right and so our do is we want to use
two I'll use colors here apologies
hopefully it'll be obvious you don't
need to know what the colors are but you
know we'll we'll kind of find two colors
like this say like in what sense is this
kind of intuitively good
okay this is the same thing we're doing
in supervised learning right we're like
this is an intuitively good thing we
talked about different loss functions
you're kind of an old hat at that so you
can kind of imagine what we're going to
do like oh the the loss in some way from
some object shouldn't be too far away
okay now the K means is hinting at that
object is going to be the mean or the
center of that cluster you kind of want
to minimize that Center cluster that's
not obvious we'll come back to it okay
so this is what we're given given data
we're given this K parameter and our
goal is to create some clustering that
we're going to talk about so we need a
little bit more notation
okay now this guy will call some point
X1 we'll call this point say X3
and that's just the notation that's
there I'm going to write the notation
formally in a second okay but before I
do that is it clear kind of what the
setup is you give me some points you
don't tell me any labels you'll also
tell me how many clusters you're looking
for and then it's my job to find them
find those clusters and we'll talk about
how to make that precise and formal in a
second
awesome so I'll just write down some
notation and if there are any questions
please
thanks
I'll show you that notation in just one
second so yeah let me write the notation
down and I'll come back to what I'm
calling there great question also on the
Ed thread sorry that I forgot to do it
earlier someone's asking what about the
unknown K case we'll come back to how to
select K later some of our algorithms as
we'll see just to go ahead some of our
algorithms will actually have a natural
test for K we'll be able to basically
try all the different K's and pick one
some of them will not and it will be a
modeling decision and let's come back to
that question for how K is unknown it's
not by the way it's not super
unrealistic that K isn't known you may
know by looking at your data that
roughly you think there are about three
or four products or something that
people are talking about or various
different topics and those are the kinds
of situations you will need kind of
k-means in but let's come back to it
great question on the Ed thread all
right so let me give you some proper
notation so we can actually you know
talk about this maybe a little bit more
mathematically we won't be super heavy
on that today okay
so what we're given in general is sum X1
to xn that live in some some Vector
space and here we're given some K which
is the number of clusters okay
[Music]
we need one bit of notation to do this
so how do we how am I going to make
these colors into notation well I'm
going to introduce this thing we're
going to find and assign oops find an
assignment
of points to clusters
points
to clusters
okay so how do we do that to the K
clusters so what we're going to have is
we're going to have a map that's called
CI equals J means
point I
to Cluster J
okay
so here I is going to run from
1 to n
and Jay is going to be you know from 1
to K right these are the same
this K and this K are the same okay
so back to this I was drawing I got a
little ahead of myself I started to draw
the notation before giving it this is
just saying we can call this point X1
this point X3 I'm just noting down what
the what the points themselves are and
then what our goal is to find this map
that I drew by by kind of this
highlighted color and that's going to be
this c i j character here so this is you
know higher than yellow for reasons I'm
not really sure why I picked yellow okay
so for example
c 3 equals 2
encodes this fact that C3 is in cluster
two and I made the green cluster 2. so
0.3
and cluster two okay
okay this will sound kind of opaque at
the moment but this is a hard assignment
we're saying every Point belongs to
exactly one cluster the reason I'm
signaling that is in the end of the
lecture we'll talk about a soft
assignment where we we have a different
version of this okay but that's what
this is
any anything that's uh you know obtuse
about the setup
all right let's see an algorithm
all right so let me copy this piece
drag it over there
all right get rid of these characters
because we don't see them and this is
our input okay so the question we want
to ask is how do we find the Clusters
find the Clusters now there are many
ways to do this and if your complexity
kind of nerd then you would say like you
know is there a you know polynomial time
you know algorithm for this and all the
rest answer is no actually it turns out
there's an MP hard problem so we're
going to have to use a heuristic based
algorithm to do this and let's see the
most natural kind of iterative approach
here okay
so how does it work
okay so here's the idea we're going to
start by randomly picking cluster
centers
and then what we're going to try and do
is the way we're thinking about key
means is we're going to try and find our
clusters as two that are described by
two cluster centers so intuitively let
me just jump back sorry about this jump
back we'll kind of try and find a point
say like here and a point here that are
good cluster centers and they're cluster
centers in the sense that all the points
in their cluster are closer to the
center than than they are to any other
Center okay and that's how we're gonna
that's how we're going to construct our
cij
so we'll start by picking these means
the means we you know where are we going
to pick if we knew where to pick them
optimally like we'd be done so we just
pick them randomly to start with so I'll
pick the cluster Center for two up here
and I'll pick the cluster Center for one
down here oops I'm going to use a
different color for
deep-seated reasons now for no reason I
just like different colors
okay sound good so I just picked those
points
maybe I want to move this one just to
make my life a little bit easier I'm
going to delete that and drag it over
you say why are you dragging over
because it's like a cooking show and I
want to make it just look a little nicer
when I draw the pictures
yeah
these were not list of points these are
just two random initialized points on
the plane I just randomly picked them in
Rd we'll talk about a smarter way to
initialize them in a second but just for
the moment they're just random points
they are not points they do not have to
be points in that you're given yeah
we'll talk about how to initialize them
later and you may not exactly want to do
that but you want to do something
similar okay
so okay so let's see how the algorithm
runs so the first thing is what would
the clustering be if these were the sent
if these were the centroids these were
the center points oh go ahead
means sorry yeah I wrote above it this
is called Kings
great question please
so for the moment K is going to be given
to us as input we'll come back as I
talked about about how to select K in a
minute but let's run through the
algorithm once and see how it works then
we'll talk about kind of what goes wrong
and and how to extend it these are
wonderful questions really great
questions are there others
awesome okay we'll come back to that and
please both questions please come back
to those as I said all right so the
first thing is we have these randomly
centered cluster points okay so this is
our first step of the algorithm is that
we're randomly initializing cluster
points randomly initialize
uh mu1 and mu2 copy paste oops got more
than I bargained for boom
uh and this one
based okay so we just randomly
initialize where those characters live
okay two
we then assign
each point to a cluster
okay and the way we do it is which point
are you closest to so I think you know
if my drawing is okay those are all you
know closer to Mu one
and maybe
this one and and these couple are closer
to Mewtwo okay
because you're clear enough what I've
done this this is the cluster assignment
and I can write it kind of
mathematically in one second if you'd
like I'll actually I'll vamp a little
bit and say how I did this more
precisely
X over J
1 to K
oh sorry I'm in all right Max
argument
uh C or mu
let me write this clear
going on
mu J minus X
I
okay I'm going to put a square there
just because I I like squares because we
do it not really too problematic so and
they're the same distance so this says
CI where I'm mapping the ith Point well
I just find the closest mu J to it my
current mu J okay that's the way I'm
doing the assignment every Point goes to
its closest neighbor and I'm like
arbitrarily saying this guy's closer
than Mewtwo
all right now I have to improve my
clustering because remember it's
iterative so what do I do
I'm going to copy it so you can so I
don't have to overwrite it what happens
well what do you think I should do I
should probably take the points that I
have and compute a new center my new
guess at the center of the Clusters
so what I do is I compute new cluster
centers
what does that mean
cluster centers
so I'm going to move I look at mu here
what's the new cluster Center for that
boom boom well it looks like it should
be somewhere here
right this is where mu1 goes and where
should mu2 go
well probably somewhere right here right
that's kind of the mean of them
okay now you can compute these things
precisely but I'm just drawing them just
so you get an intuition
okay and I'll write this notation
because there's more notation so now I
have new cluster centers
now what's the next step
I repeat
so I go back and I assign
every set that's closer to Mu 1 or mu 2.
so now I have these characters
and I have these characters there
okay that's what that's now doing step
two again
I repeat step three
what's gonna happen they're gonna jump
to the spot in the middle and the spot
in the middle
new One's Gonna Be there mu2 and then
there's gonna be no more change if I
were to continue running the algorithm
forever
so let me write that out mathematically
while you digest that statement that's
the entire algorithm okay so what does
this mean mu J is going to equal
1 over Sigma J
it's going to be some average over all
the points in Sigma J
x i
such that Sigma J is is just the set of
points uh I such that CI equals J okay
this is just some notation that says
these are all the points that are close
to closest to the center J
and then I average over all of them I
just compute their mean hence K means
okay I iterate this thing
and I repeat until no until no
assignments change until nothing changes
basically
repeat until nothing changes notice that
if the labels don't change in step two
then the mean is not going to change
because it's a function of the labels
right it's a function of like what I
guessed was in each cluster it's always
their mean
any questions about that nothing changes
please
in many many in different ways so let's
let's talk about a couple of things that
go right and then we'll talk about what
goes wrong so the first way it could go
wrong is does it terminate right so if
you imagine it was in some you know it's
not obvious like I'm doing this kind of
jumping around it could oscillate wildly
right like there's nothing that like
prevents it at least at a high level
when you're thinking about this of going
like oh one switch from wet red to blue
then it switched back from Blue to red
and then the cluster centers are like
jumping around and there's in some
unstable kind of equilibrium so that's
something that potentially could be bad
that happens so that's the first
question does it terminate
does it terminate
all right and it turns out this is great
yes does now why does it the reason is
that this functional underneath the
covers
one to n
x i minus mu CI
that is the distance between a point and
its cluster Center is actually
monotonically decreasing it's not
increasing so that that oscillation
can't happen basically and you can you
can basically view the algorithm
underneath this K means if you really
want to be kind of super abstract you
can view it as basically doing gradient
descent on this object in a particular
way see the notes for actually the
convergence so it converges to something
okay now an unsupervised learning that
converges to something is about as is
kind of what we can hope for in
particular you may also ask okay it
converts to something does it converge
to a global minimizer
does it converge
to Global minimizer and if I did my job
setting this up your intuition should
say
no
no not necessarily
now you may look at this and say well
not necessarily maybe there's a better
algorithm out there that given this
setup of problem you just you know why
did you pick this algorithm it's a bad
algorithm you should show me a better
one there isn't a better one because
it's actually MP hard if you don't know
what that means don't worry there's no
hardness proofs in this class does not
really matter it just means we don't
know like Humanity does not know a
better algorithm for this that runs in
polynomial time okay and we have reason
to suspect there isn't one
okay
all right so this is this algorithm as I
said like it's going to run but
sometimes it can end up doing things
that are like you know quite bad in
particular gets stuck by like getting a
cluster over in a region where it should
have never been and if it like had you
know more carefully searched potentially
could have gotten a lower cost solution
all right
clear enough clear enough on its
properties now this this is going to be
a Hallmark of what we do over the next
couple of lectures almost everything we
do with the exception of one algorithm
that we'll talk about has this property
that it doesn't necessarily converge to
a global optimized solution and as I
said this used to be much more
disturbing to people but now most of AI
is in that mode so people don't seem to
care as much okay used to be quite
disturbing when I started it was quite
disturbing now no one cares you guys you
folks are old hats at this go ahead
so this
is
what happens the next situation so you
can imagine situations for example
imagine there are points that are really
far away and then some other cluster of
points here and that really there's
enough kind of things in the middle that
the optimal is actually closer to the to
the line then what you'll see is that if
you could you could end up with some
kind of some kind of local minimum where
you pick a center way way over here and
a center in the middle of this but you
should have there was a kind of a better
one closer so that's very hand wavy I
can post some examples where you can
actually run through and convince
yourself all that I really care to get
across in this lecture and I couldn't
think of how to like get good examples
to look up there is that this is a
possibility you shouldn't expect it to
get you a global minimizer and we have
some theoretical reason why we don't
believe such an algorithm could exist
even in this simple case yeah wonderful
okay now
a couple of side notes so these
questions already came up so these are
really great so they're not even side
notes they're just responding they're
being responsive but I was going to talk
about them no matter what
the question was asked how did you
initialize right how did you pick these
points and from my argument as I just
talked about even very intuitively and
informally the initialization matters
quite a bit right if you initialize way
way in crazy ways then you force came in
to kind of jump back and maybe there's
only one point like imagine there's a
cluster of point and you throw one of
your centers way across the room it's
gonna you know potentially pick off
nothing and then it's going to have to
you know kind of crawl its way back in
some sense so the point that I care
about you getting is how does the
um how does initialization you know
matter and I won't go into too much
detail but I want to tell you that
there's one algorithm that was developed
by smart Stanford students
a while ago maybe 12 years ago I don't
know 12 15 years ago maybe even called
k-means plus plus and I'll just you know
tell you or what what they did
from great Stanford students
and basically what they decided to do is
that they where they compute kind of a
density estimation and then they they
Place their centers with respect to the
density to kind of spread them out in a
in a nice way and k-means plus plus and
without going too much into the details
what ends up happening is they get an
improved approximation ratio so if you
don't care about this kind of theory
stuff don't worry but they're able to
show that if you initialize in this way
even though it's MP hard to find the
exact solution they can find kind of a
low cost approximate algorithm to it
provably so this is actually when we
were talking about what could go wrong
this is something that can go wrong and
what people do in k-means is they used
to just kind of run it many times but if
you run with this initialization it's
still a random initialization but if you
run it a couple of times you're going to
get a pretty good solution and because
you're already kind of looking for an
ill-defined kind of objective that turns
out to be about okay
now weirdly enough like I used to as I
said I didn't really like this stuff but
I wrote a paper about using some of it
inside some of making these machine
learning models robust maybe a year or
two ago so it is something that like you
know I've actually used and care about
like it does work and and you use it as
a way to inspect your data off it like
you don't you look at your data set you
kind of do your k-means clustering then
you can use that to figure out like you
know what are the different groups that
are inside okay
all right this thing here became the
default and scikit-learn uh and sklearn
so these folks wrote this beautiful
paper they proved this nice result and
now if you run a psychic learn and run
the k-means algorithm it defaults to
using the excuse me defaults to using
the k-means plus plus initialization
okay so pretty fun Sergey and folks did
that
anyway all right so now there's another
question which was okay how do you
choose K right this came up both in the
Ed thread and it came up uh in the
lecture hall itself how do you choose K
and here's the problem with choosing k
there's no one right answer
we'll see other unsupervised algorithms
which do give a right answer but let me
just illustrate this for you for one
second suppose I give you this
data set
okay
there's two copies of it
one reasonable clustering is this
two clusters
equally reasonable excuse me
is
this one
four clusters
now
if you think about the algorithm as
giving you the right answer of what
structure is inside your data then you
really don't like this answer say well
what's the right k
well it's not the right way to think
about it maybe the right way to think
about it is given that you have a k can
you use this as a tool to find the
Clusters that are in there of different
sizes so if you're looking for five
clusters and you really only found you
know you look at the five cluster and
the four cluster map you have to make
some judgment about kind of which one is
better underneath the covers and that's
why unsupervised learning is kind of
squishy but it also turns out to be
tremendously powerful so we can automate
the loop of finding the Clusters but you
know which one is good or bad you're
going to have to use domain knowledge
for that in most situations
okay right so this is really another way
of saying this is a modeling question so
the one part you know even when I didn't
really
care for I don't know what I'm telling
you the history of how I feel about
lecture 11 but like you know you're
getting it so but like one of the things
that I did like about this lecture
always or this this part of the course
is that it forced machine learning folks
to move out of the comfort zone of like
there's a right answer and optimization
will find it which was very disturbing
to me because that's not at all how
machine learning works and what you're
doing you're constantly in this regime
where you're checking if your model
works or breaks or does things I don't
know how much a technique subjected you
to my crazy slides but like that is the
way that you live when you're building
these kind of ml systems like you build
a model you have no idea if it worked
you have to check it you have to look at
it you have to inspect it you have to
measure it
um so this is kind of natural at least
forces you to do that okay that's all I
want to say about key means I want to
jump to the next algorithm which is
building towards this larger theory of
what we did and if you can kind of
squint you'll see that it parallels how
we taught the supervised learning case
but any questions before I move on
awesome
please is this something you might use
if you're doing supervised learning but
with labels that you're not sure about
oh awesome yeah great question so let's
say that you're on super buy here so the
way we were actually using it is exactly
in that way in this paper what we were
looking for I'll just to be really
concrete is we were looking for what are
called hidden stratification so these
are times when a machine learning model
let's say that it's classifying uh birds
that are on the land versus birds that
are in the water I have more elaborate
examples than this and it turns out that
the model sometimes gets confused by the
background and so what you want to do is
you want to Cluster some notion of those
like feature descriptors underneath the
covers of like background descriptors
that the neural net has learned to try
and find a group which kind of looks
like an oddball from the rest so it's
like oh here's all the land Birds on
land backgrounds I got them all right
and there's this other weird cluster
there that I labeled as land Birds but
actually our water birds that happen to
be walking on land right and so that's
the kind of thing you look into your
your like labels or your Suitor labels
or your predictions and try and find
those it can either be labels that are
given to you by a human or a neural net
and that is like one of that was you
know the use case that I had is exactly
what you what you thought about
um yeah so that's one of them you'll
typically also run this when you have
like you honestly when you have data you
don't really understand so like you run
an experiment with you know search
traffic or ad traffic or something and
you're like what the heck are people
asking about in this segment and then
you run kind of a clustering to figure
it out and say like oh this this looks
like a topic that people are talking
about X Y or Z right so those are the
other times that that you use it but
noisy labels is a good thing and that
will be a theme for next week's lectures
great question
please
yeah so the question is if you pick a
larger number of clusters then like if
we go to this example here
the problem is how descriptive does it
get so in four and two you could kind of
eyeball the two and the four and and
link them up but if you start to really
Jack it up to like a thousand then it
like is like kind of at the brink of
what does it mean to find meaningful
Concepts right so if you're looking for
10 things and you know there are 10
things you want to find those 10 best
groups if you start to jack it up to a
thousand ten thousand it no longer
becomes like human digestible so that's
where the modeling thing comes in it's
kind of like the bandwidth of what you
can look at and do this and and
traditionally k-means was not used in an
automated Loop it was traditionally used
as like a way to browse your data if the
consumer of that is some neural net in
the discussion we were talking about
then it kind of doesn't matter you can
jack it up a little bit more the
advantage of doing so the advantage of
doing that is if you put too many
centers they may be too close together
and sometimes what people do is they'll
just do a kind of a follow-on path where
they merge some clusters that look like
they're kind of not informative a
pruning heuristic at the end so your
intuition is dead on and like that's the
side you want to err on if you air on
the side of two small clusters what
happens you lump two things together
that you could have distinguish and then
you could get like a weird cluster in
the center so clearly you're right the
over provision setting is much nicer
than the under provision setting
awesome it sounds like folks got it
please
[Music]
yeah so so I wish there was one
algorithm so this is something that like
people are writing still writing
research papers on we had an iClear
paper on there's another one coming out
from some other from another group which
is great that we're reading right now
basically what people try to do and in
these things is that data point so this
is kind of an impoverished setting right
we have data points that are just in Rd
that are in a vector space but those
data points usually correspond to
Something Real like there's an image or
text and so the more modern ways that
people do with this diagnosis like what
what Sabria and folks did in and Maya
did and Domino is I said oh we took
those points and we embedded the text
that's associated with an image and the
image itself and we start to like do
kind of search queries on top to find
the slices that are underneath the
covers so this is the purest setting
where you're just like I have data from
in a vector space but of course like
with modern methods like there's an
underlying object it's a transaction or
an image and a caption and then you
start to use some of the more modern
techniques to search through it and then
of course you visualize it or monitor it
and there are a number of tools that are
out there to do this I wouldn't say it's
solved like oh you just use x and you're
done but
um you know there are a number of tools
but yeah you do have to look at your
data like there's nothing that really
obviates that
awesome questions
all right all right so let's talk about
a slight what appears at first to be a
slight generalization hopefully it feels
like
we just relax one little thing but it
gets us closer to
a more fancy model
that will allow us to do some really fun
stuff okay and this is actually pretty
fun so this is a toy example from
astronomy and if you know about
astronomy
please don't humiliate me too badly feel
free to correct me I have no idea what
I'm talking about but I read the paper
and I understood the math so okay
it's a toy example okay and it's from a
paper from the University of Washington
so I can find the paper again for people
there okay so here's the general setup
of what they're doing
they have this light detector this
Photon counting thing okay and they're
looking in the sky at various different
things
and what they want to do is they have in
this simplified model there's kind of
two celestial objects that could be out
there could be like a regular star and a
quasar okay and one of them is going to
take the light and it's going to spread
kind of evenly in all directions and
another is going to send out relatively
concentrated pulses okay and what
happens is unfortunately when those
photons come to Earth they don't come
with labels no one gets to like affix a
metadata packet to every Photon that
that hits us we have to see the photons
and figure out like where the hell do
they come from okay
so what happens we get some data that
looks like this
maybe like this
okay and these are all our little
photons that are there okay so you know
quasars and stars
now
okay and both of these things emit light
but all we get to observe are these
Photon hits
all right so now what we're going to do
in our sub oh please go ahead
assume
no we don't have to assume a linear
decision boundary we just have to assume
that it's it's close in distance right
you can get non-linear
right there's no notion of a decision
boundary in particular anyway like you
can draw like a little vornoid diagram
but we didn't talk about that very nice
question
awesome
so we get these Photon hits okay so what
we want to do
is kind of figure out you know what
these different sources look like and so
what our given or this is what we're
given
what we're going to do is try and find a
soft assignment of these things into
gaussian so remember what gaussians look
like right they're basically it's a high
probability they look like ovals right
they can be circles right that's what a
two-dimensional gaussian looks like
right and the variance tells you how
it's How stretched it is in each
Dimension okay so like maybe there's a a
cluster here cluster here and this is a
tight cluster okay
all right so we'll talk about that in
more detail in one second
but what we have to do
is we want to assign each photon
to a light source
but of course we don't actually in this
case we don't have perfect information
of the light sources either
and so we're going to settle for what we
call a soft assignment okay so this is
the probability
prob
that point
I goes to Cluster
Goes To Source J
okay and this is our soft assignment
this is called a soft assignment
okay why is it soft because we didn't
remember in K means we said you must be
in this in this setting here we have
some probability distribution over it
okay
all right so just compare that with
compare that with k-means all right
so what are the challenges here
the challenges that we that that we're
going to deal with here potentially are
there are many sources
right if there were just one source life
would be easy we would kind of fit the
gaussian you know how to do that from
GDA you take the mean you find the
variance you're done okay there are many
sources here but for now we're going to
assume we know the source is K we know K
which is the number of sources
okay let's solve the problem in that
setting okay
and also the other problem is the
sources have uh different intensities
and shapes
intensities and shapes
okay so when I was wildly drawing those
ovals the reason was is like oh maybe
there's a gaussian that looks like this
maybe there's a tight gaussian I don't
assume I know that ahead of time I just
know that they're somehow well described
by gaussians please
oh no great question so those are the
two types of things I need the number of
celestial bodies so like one reasonable
thing would be three there's one here
one here and one here but K is still
going to be picked by a modeling
assumption right so this is this this
curve is hard to generate with uh with a
gaussian in our current setup right so
there's probably not there's probably
more than one on that side but that's
just intuition there could be four there
five there I don't know
so let me let me talk about the
assumptions okay
so we're going to assume it's well
modeled
and here we're in you know most of what
I'm going to do is going to be in one
dimension so I'm still just going to
introduce the notation in one dimension
by gaussian
right and you remember that a gaussian
means mu J Sigma J Square okay so just
one dimension to make our lives similar
in a second
but we do not assume
we know how many points that there's an
equal number of points
number of points is equal
okay
now
the reason is in our setup the physical
reason is like you know some point
sources are really concentrated and
strong and they shoot out tons of
photons and in other cases they'll shoot
out you know diffuse photons over a
region that may be farther closer away
different energy levels whatever
mathematically what I mean is we don't
know when we're going to talk about
these gaussians the shape may be a
gaussian but it's only sampled
infrequently for Source one and it
sampled 90 of the time for Source two
okay
this is formally known as an unknown
mixture
okay now one thing that's nice about
this problem and the physics setting is
once I get the values out so what are
the what's the do here I have to get out
these cluster centers that we talked
about before and these probabilities
which I haven't given you notation for
but they're going to be called Phi in a
second
I can check that if how physically
plausible that clustering is right so in
the K the reason I like this example is
and the K means you kind of kind of have
to eyeball it but here if I have a
physics model I can compute How likely
is one clustering versus another given
the data sources that I'm seeing maybe
have auxiliary information about what
celestial objects are in the sky and
that particular region and so I can I
can check this information
okay and the physicists in this example
could actually check the information
please
[Music]
the range of what
J oh J is going to range the same it's
going to range over each number of
sources so we're going to assume that we
have this K number of sources here
so J Will range over K just like it did
so that's fixed that's a parameter of
the problem someone's going to tell me
basically what someone's going to tell
me is there are K sources I have don't
tell you what their means are I don't
tell you what their variances are so
that's for each one of them and I don't
tell you how often that's this mixture
they emit light so what percentage of
the points go to Source a versus Source
B
please
so so for example let's imagine that we
had a situation
like uh let me just draw it so let's say
that we had you know three points here
and then I'm not going to draw them all
but like a thousand points here so there
are three points here and a thousand
points here right so the clustering that
I would want out is one cluster here and
one cluster here
but I don't get to see the three and one
thousand
I'm assuming that they're of unequal
sizes so you could for example assume
that all the Clusters are equal sizes
I'm trying to and that would be a that
would be wrong and this is not the way
we'd have the model that's a fair
assumption if you knew that right but
that would make your life a lot easier
it doesn't make you have to solve both
of these two things
awesome question
all right please yeah
we make that assumption kind of
implicitly because we don't say how
often like there's no probabilistic
model but we do allow K to have like
five neighbors and 500 neighbors right
center cluster one could have five
neighbors another one could have 500 so
it does parallel k mean so in that sense
it's the same assumption I'm calling it
out here as an extra parameter that we
didn't have to think about last time
right
awesome questions
okay let's see some 1D mixture of
gaussians mixture of gaussians is like a
very fun and famous Problem by the way
um people like work on like which ones
you can solve
um
in theory still it's like a fun it's
actually fun and interesting problem
we won't do that
all right so I'm going to be in 1D for
Simplicity here
because it just makes my notation and
drawing easier so I have to draw
distributions all right so just make
sure it's super clear what we're doing I
think folks sound like they have it so
we have 1D this is going to be the the
place where our points live and then
imagine
there were
two
gaussians that were generating data okay
now when I say this generating data this
is the piece like when I talked about we
were going to talk we're going to allow
ourselves to talk about models we're
going to imagine that there's really a
model that's underneath our data that's
generating it okay this is a quite a
powerful technique
okay so how does it work
what we're going to do
our our idea for the model is we're
going to pick you know cluster one with
some probability let's call it P or
cluster two with probability one minus P
we pick cluster one we then sample a
point
oops let me get a thicker thing
all right
oops that's probably too thick
and we get a series of points
okay
that's the thought process that we're
going through right there if we only
knew those parameters we could sample
from our model if we knew the
probability to pick cluster one versus
cluster two
and then we would sample from it and
there's many different parameters given
that model that could have generated our
data and we're interested in recovering
the ones that are most likely that most
likely generated our data okay now what
we see
unfortunately
is just this
just the points
okay so this is the the model over here
this is what we observe oops
which back
just the points in r
okay these are the X I's
now
one thing and this is going to seem like
a trivial
piece but it actually makes our life
kind of interesting what if we knew
these points all came from cluster one
and these points claim from cluster two
okay this is our first observation
well if we knew the cluster labels what
would algorithm would we run
we just run something like GDA we would
just fit gaussians to this we'd be done
right so if we knew this we could just
solve this instantly solve and fit
gaussians
so we compute
you know mu I
mu 1 mu2 how do we do that well we would
just average up all the things in here
average up all the things in here that
was bbr Muse and we could even compute
the sigmas and be done the challenge is
we don't get to see them
we don't get those labels
challenge
we only see
this thing
okay
this is our first example of a latent
model there's something hidden that we
don't observe and we're trying to
estimate the parameters of that model
and that'll be a theme for the next
couple lectures
please
[Music]
sure yep
oh so this is this is yeah so this was
an example to motivate like hey this is
like a nice picture to look at and kind
of get you thinking empirically about
what happens I'm going to walk through
most of these things in 1D because it
makes my notation a lot easier and so
there's really no relationship between
uh like these points and the points I
showed you before yeah great question
awesome
all right so why am I doing it in this
kind of like piecemeal way is because
when I show you the definition then you
know it has a bunch of notation in it
and I want to show you the simplest
version so that then you can generalize
it and do all that fun stuff on your own
all right but it is it clear what the
what goes on here there's this notion
I've introduced and kind of sneaked into
you which is the model right there's
some parameter P here that picks this
side or this side right which is going
to be called Theta
Theta 1 and Theta 2.
hinting later
I pick something and then I sample from
it if I knew where the points came from
I could just solve
but the problem is I have this hidden
how often is everything sampled I don't
know how many points should be in each
cluster and I don't know which points
are in the cluster not only do I not you
know I don't know either of those facts
so we have to estimate them somehow from
data that's what we're going to do
okay so let's see some notation and we
can come back to this example if if
there are more questions about it okay
so let me be a little bit more
precise
so we're given X1
x n element of R okay and a positive
integer K and K you know positive
integer or a number of sources
and our do what we're given what we have
what we have to do is we need to find
that probability function find P such
that for I equals 1 to n j equals 1 to K
the Clusters
this is the data
we have an estimate of p z i equals J
this is our notion of soft assignment
okay so that's what we're responsible
okay and this is although it's a
function it's discrete so I can write it
down right I can just write down the
probabilities in a table
we'll later worry about cases that's not
the case but for now we do
make sense
[Music]
no so J is a cluster index and K is the
number of clusters so J here says this
says the ice Point belongs to Cluster J
with some probability
J ranges over one to K so they are K
clusters
K was equal we we never actually were
precise about what K is we had rough
intuition that K should be at least
three and I don't think we actually use
J or if I did I meant and scribbled it
incorrectly and I apologize probably was
a wayward eye but I don't I don't I
don't see it in my notes but apologies
for that
I'm sorry for the confusion
please
that
the sample height belongs to clusters
each uh belongs or comes from yeah so I
I'll copy from here is this this
sentence
probability of that point I belongs to I
think it should be I think is what I
meant to write I think that's better
probably a point I uh comes from source
that makes more sense in English
from Source J yeah
yeah Source J is the particular source
always a particular source so I is
always the data J is always the label
for the cluster and K is always the
number of clusters
please
uh that in X Oh you mean from the uh
no
um
uh so yeah so z i is the assignment so z
i is the is the soft assignment itself x
i is the data point yeah sorry for the
overloading the notation so the zis will
always be the hidden piece that says the
so let me write the next sentence the
next uh piece and then we'll come right
back to your question I can see why
you'd be be confused by that
so let me write the GMM model and you'll
see why these two things are being used
according to the GMM model
so z i is just that z i is the random
variable that this probability that
point belongs to it it's not the actual
point itself so then for example we can
talk about the probability of x i and z
i
this is the probability that given this
point and the zi is that it belongs to a
particular cluster
um and we'll write down the model in one
second so let me write down the model
and then it'll be clear what this
notation means
okay all right this is just Bayes rule
nothing fancy here I said nothing
there's no content
okay but I'll use it now z i
is going to be distributed as a
multinomial
According to some parameter that we'll
call Phi and Phi has a multinomial is
says that some Phi J
goes from 1 to K
equals 1 and Phi J is greater than or
equal to zero okay so Z J if you like is
that sampling probability like it's the
the likelihood that this particular
Point came from that that place and Zi
is going to be picked with this
background probability that we're
calling P before so in our earlier
example there was like P and 1 minus P
were the chance that I sampled from
cluster 1 or cluster 2 above here
okay these are Phi 1 and Phi 2. that's
what I was hinting at
okay
and remember in our model like I picked
di that told me where I was sampling
and then once I knew Zi
x i
given that z i equals J that means given
that it was in cluster J this is going
to be distributed like a gaussian
mu J
igma J Square
okay so these are all gaussians
okay now let me highlight for you the
parameters we have to estimate
highlighted parameters
okay
this thing
with this thing okay
all right these are the same color so
what's going on here this is formalizing
the model that we talked about earlier
it's our first kind of hidden model we
never see Zi
we don't observe it in data we don't get
to see the labels
you know the deity or whoever is
generating his data generates a Zi
and picks one of the Clusters that's its
sample for this point and then it
samples
from this normal distribution to
generate x i
and if you like the data we think about
as being the remnants of this process
we don't get to see this process run it
gets run ahead of time and then the data
is dropped there and the reason we're
thinking about this model is we say Okay
assuming that the model were like this
could we recover the parameters
okay and so that's the sense in which
we're assuming there's some structure
and it's pretty reasonable what it's
saying is look I don't know how many
points come from every cluster that's
because I have a multinomial and two I
know that the points that I the Clusters
that I have they're gaussian shaped but
I don't know if they're circles or all
ovals and I don't know where their
centers are
and I'm assuming nothing else
about my structure can you find it for
me that's your job does that make sense
you have to come up with we have to come
up with these parameters we have to find
the cluster centers and the
probabilities that each are sampled from
observing the data
right clearly if I pick one clustering
it's going to the data is going to be
very unlikely have to have been
generated with those centers right like
if I go back here and I pick the center
over here in the center over here that's
less likely than if I put the center
here in the center here
right it would just explain the data
less well we'll be able to formalize
that with maximum likelihood but I hope
that intuition is clear if it's not
please go ahead ask me a question I'm
super happy to answer
ah so Phi is basically just a bunch of
numbers that sum to one it's a
multinomial so this is a probability I I
like if I have class cluster one like so
let's say this is going back here
let's say this is cluster one cluster
two cluster three or Source one two and
three
and lots of points are in Source One so
then maybe Phi one would be like point
seven right because they're like seventy
percent of the data is there and ten
percent of the data is here and twenty
percent of the data is here then the
numbers would be point seven point one
point two
roughly does that make sense awesome
right
all right
all right so let me let's do one example
um I just wanna I'm trying let me see
call the zi latent
because we don't observe it we didn't
get to see it right we just got to see
the points we didn't get to see which
was assigned to which cluster
because it's not directly observable
this concept which seems at this point
like kind of strange I would think about
a bunch and we'll see it again and again
this is what we mean by structure we're
like well there's some wild collection
of points but like there exists a small
number of clusters that are generating
them that's the mathematical embodiment
of what this thing is the mathematical
embodiment of that intuition that's all
it is and we say if that's the case then
we should be able to recover it
okay we should be able to recover those
clusters in those situations and in the
physical situation of like light sources
that seems pretty plausible right like
you know
they have different intensities
different shapes so on
all right so let me give you one more
example just to make sure that all these
terms are
this notation is there and I want you to
think in sampling
and let me just walk through so
hopefully these things make sense so Phi
1 is going to be 0.7 if I2 is going to
be 0.3 why are those the numbers because
I'm making them up that's why don't have
another reason Phi 1 is going to be one
mu 1 is going to be 1 mu 2 is going to
be 2 and I'm going to set Sigma 1 square
equals Sigma 2 square is about a third
roughly okay so what does that picture
look like
here we go
there's one
there's two
thing here if I draw it pretty well
maybe my drawing is off but hopefully
you get the point this thing should be
about a third this distance should be
about a third the fact that they're
uneven is because I'm a bad artist not
because that's the intention of the
thing
this is mu1
this is mu2
okay and this distance here should be
about a third
the 65 thing it's a standard deviation
okay how do I sample from it first I
pick a cluster pick one either one or
two one of my clusters I picked the
first cluster with probability 0.7 the
second with point three
then I pick the relevant mean so if I
picked two I will use mu 2
I go over here then I will sample from a
gaussian and generate myself a point let
me hear
two use the appropriate gaussian
okay so imagine that this were the
process that we're generating your data
you just get to see an instance of the
data your goal is to say what's the most
likely process that generated it
okay and that corresponds to this
intuition like there exists some
clusters
so far so good oh and then you repeat
repeat
yeah please go ahead and ask questions
no yeah so that would be if they if I
wrote their probability distributions
entirely these are still unit normal
gaussians this is a great question I
drew it as two gaussians I didn't draw
the Phi 1 and Phi 2. I Incorporated them
just in this first set so I would pick
you know Phi 1 I would pick one with
probability 0.7
like one 0.7 right and you could imagine
re-weighting them and and normalizing
them but then it's just a little
confusing visually and I'm not that good
of an artist
because we don't know how many points
come from every source so remember going
back to to this one up here
we had like the oops I went way too far
back
here we had lots of points from this one
source and this point you know they're
70 coming from here 30 coming from here
15 or 20 coming from there and so they
they we can't we're just not assuming
that they have the same if we force them
all to have equally sized clusters we
would probably put two cluster centers
Here If This Were seventy percent of the
points and we would we would use that to
explain our data that would be in this
case sub-optimal right that's just our
modeling choice we know that the
Clusters have different number of points
in our application so that's why we we
fit them we can't assume they're the
same if we knew them perfectly we knew
the things we could we could sneak them
in there but we'll talk about where we
sneak them in later
[Music]
the shape
they understand they understand the
shape really yeah yeah awesome
sure
um
foreign
that's kind of good man I mean
but like should the second Peak be
actually shorted at first yeah that's a
great question so you could imagine for
folding the files in to try and make
them both probability distribution
density functions where there was one
distribution density function and then
you would fold them in I've drawn them
crudely having the same height and
putting the probability function up
front to say these are the gaussians and
then there's a height but you've got it
perfectly yeah that's another way to
visualize it which is if this is beyond
my architecture artistic abilities like
that's Legions Beyond so yeah wonderful
question no no no no no that's a lion I
I do not have a lot of my ego tied up in
that yeah
[Music]
awesome so what's going on here the the
trick that we're gonna do is we're going
to assume like okay so every time you
set one of these values
you give me a distribution right that
gives me a distribution so now I have an
infinite number of these things that are
out there with different settings of Phi
different cluster centers different
samplings so now imagine your head like
I grabbed one of them and then I did the
sampling process and it generates some
data okay great so we understand that
piece now I I what what happens though
in our problem is we're going to invert
that process so we see some data just to
XIs themselves and now we want to select
among all those infinite things that are
out there which are parameterized now by
these fives and mu's and sigmas which
one is most likely the one that
generated our data and intuitively we
know as I said like if the cluster
centers are super far apart and our data
is all in the middle that one's probably
less likely that one that has a cluster
centers closer we're going to be precise
in a second about how we fit that but
you can kind of see where it's going to
come from is this model
so in the same way we use maximum
likelihood before we'll get there we're
going to do a little bit more intuition
we're going to say that the parameters
that generated our data are the most
likely ones after we've seen the data so
we'll condition on the data and try to
invert it to find it so this this
thinking of like the latent forward
process is super weird right and so yeah
you're exactly right does that make
sense though we think about the process
and then we're like oh if we inverted it
that's kind of what it must have been
right this yeah go ahead
and do that for various sets of
different parameters
exactly right the the thing is we want
to be exactly right we could just guess
all the parameters or try all of them
promise there's infinitely many so the
questions can we solve them and find
them faster than that right but if we
could just in theory you know there's
well and theory is a weird statement
because there's uncountably many of them
but like we could conceptually try all
the parameters and then see which one
was like closest in probability you know
had the highest likelihood score and
we're going to try and that's going to
be our gold standard of what we want to
pull out you got it perfectly please
foreign
if there's only one value then you know
everything came from one source and
you're just fitting a gaussian and the
most likely estimate for a gaussian is
as you saw from GDA and everything else
is average your data to compute the mean
and then compute the variance from that
and then you and then you have it
perfectly wonderful
awesome we got this all right so let's
see the algorithm that does this because
it mirrors our friend k-means okay
okay
we're also studying this by the way
because this same pattern will repeat
itself in our next lecture
it's a famous algorithm so it's fun to
know about
and it's important pedagogically I don't
know if you actually have to do anything
with it in the class but and it mirrors
k-means so like why are you teaching me
these two things they seem to differ in
small ways and that difference like
k-means seems a lot more intuitive than
this whole infinite number of models
that we're selecting among but we want
to get to that world view so that we
want to relate the two
okay so one
there's an e-step okay so this em is
very famous and we'll come back to that
in a second here we guess just as you
put it perfectly we guess the latent
values
which in this thing are the values of
the zis
okay so we guess all of the cluster
centers their distributions okay by hook
or we just figure it out okay that's our
first piece we'll see how we do that in
a more intuitive way and then the m-step
we update the other parameters
so if we knew the distributions we knew
my observation one if we knew where
every Point came from
then we could just run GDA on it we
could just run you know find which
gaussians are in each set we just fit
all of them there's a slight twist that
we're going to not know where precisely
every point is we're going to know them
a distribution so we have to do
something a little bit more complicated
but not too much more complicated
okay
this is our first example of a very
famous algorithm
first example of em is like a very very
famous algorithm that people like use
for decades
I don't want to oversell it I have a
colleague and friend who says you only
run it when you don't know what you're
doing and he's right in the sense he's
kind of a curmudgeon it's a good dude
but he's right in the sense that like if
you knew exactly what you were looking
for you wouldn't run this algorithm but
that's precisely where it's interesting
because when you run these kind of em
algorithms you know something about the
setup okay all right so let's see
mathematically what this looks like and
in your head you should be thinking how
do I what did I do in k-means
the e-step
so here we're given the data
and
current values
which are guesses
for
Phi Mu Sigma blah blah blah all the
stuff Sigma 1 mu 1 mu two whatever U1
all the parameters okay and our our do
is we have to
predict
Zi
okay 4i equals 1 to n
all right
now
I'm going to introduce the notation here
following our notes
given x i
by mu
Sigma okay so what's going on okay this
is our goal
okay so what do we want we want to
compute these weights which I'm just
giving a new notation to because Z's
will be changing as we run and all the
rest
we're given the data point condition on
that so we know the point we're looking
at we know all the rest of the
parameters the likelihoods the the
frequencies with which we're sampling
from each one of them we have our
current guess we have our current guess
of how where the center of every cluster
source is and it's
um you know variance and now what we
want to do is we want to compute How
likely a particular point is to belong
to a cluster intuitively if it's really
close the probability should be high to
the cluster Center if it's a really you
know if it's really far away it should
be close to zero but it's continuous
it's not going to be zero itself okay
because the gaussian doesn't go to zero
you know anywhere okay so how do we do
this
well it's nothing more than Bayes rules
Bayes rule
okay
oops
Sigma
oops over
all right
okay
all right so all I've done here is
something really simple I've taken x i
which I've conditioned on it and I've
kind of divided it up so this is like
kind of the likelihood of the data being
generated with this which is a
probability and then these two things
being jointly done together then I'm
gonna I'm gonna Factor them out as I sum
over all of the different probabilities
okay so this is going to be equal to
probability of x i
okay oops
z i given J probability of z i
J
over
sum
if you use l here instead of J because I
don't want to confuse what we're doing
z i
equals l
comma the whole thing
p z i
equals l
okay
so the point is
we know all of these functions okay oh
sorry and everything here by the way has
like is has this stuff we know all that
information so that's everywhere okay
okay so we know
all of the estimates in our guess so
what is this probability right here
well if we knew the the that it was a
condition that we knew that this point
came from the cluster well it's just
nothing more than our friend the
gaussian right this is this character
right here uh which I'll highlight
this is just a gaussian we know that
from the model right
so is this
right so if I can be really explicit
about it it's like you know X above x i
minus mu I
Square over 2 Sigma I
square right
times some normalizing constant 1 over
the square root of 2 pi right
so we know what this is
what's this one
those are our fives
so this character here
oops I shouldn't use that color
this is Phi J
this is Phi l
so I've decomposed the problem once I
know it into estimating
all of these quantities which I already
kind of mechanically know how to compute
okay so the key point is we can compute
all the terms
compute all the terms
now this isn't super surprising so maybe
you look at this and you're like wow
that's just a bunch of weird notation
what the heck is he talking about look
this is just k-means it's saying in some
kind of generalized sense it's saying I
need to compute a probability
distribution function okay k-means
doesn't need to do that but how does it
do it it says well I consider the
probability that this x I was generated
from this J I Know How likely it is that
a point came from it I know given How
likely once I'm in the point what the
probability of this data point is and
then what I'm going to do is I'm going
to compare it
to the likelihood from every other
cluster
and that's the probability right
that's all that's encoding instead of
having that hard assignment and saying
which one's closest like and K means
this was just a Mac said look at all the
other clusters and you picked the
closest one now I'm going to average
over it and I'm just averaging over it
with Bayes rule
and it looks like notation is a bunch of
notation but it's not super scary
it's just things you know how to compute
go ahead
what's
they wouldn't be zero but they'd be very
close to zero so what would happen in
that scenario so in your point let's say
x i is really close to this particular J
so this thing is very it's not going to
be one because the height of the thing
is not exactly one but it's going to be
some high number let's say you know 0.5
or something so some big big number okay
then over here let's say 5j that's the
other term so if Phi J like were equal
across all the Clusters we'll come back
to what happens when it's not in a
second if it's equal across all the
Clusters we get you know 0.5 times you
know one over five or something or five
clusters one over five and then we
compare that likelihood to the rest of
these and because you said these were
really really far away what happens here
you get this term repeated right so you
get exactly that one term plus a bunch
of things which are super close to zero
and so as a result this thing will be
very very close to one yeah does that
make sense now what happens just in that
inference
if if Phi J were very very close to zero
so now there's this trade-off as the
point you know if the point is like you
know there's the cluster Center and it's
closed but I think it's extremely
unlikely like my 5j is like 10 to the
minus 10 and I've only seen a thousand
points I still don't consider it very
likely that this Source actually
generated something okay in that setting
and that's all Bayes rule does in
general is trade off those two things
does that make sense yeah awesome
okay
right now back to the oh please
the probability of x i is the
probability density yeah so I use them
okay so yes so you can do this because
you can use the likelihood ratios in
this way but there and this is the
correct thing to do from Bayes rule but
it's a little bit sticky because like
this is just a PDF but the fact that
it's like normalized up to it allows
this thing to go through but yeah you're
exactly right yeah it's a little squishy
but it it works wonderful question
awesome so I hope I hope what you got
from this is and also I wanted to come
back so that whole weird rant about like
how the data are generated is now
mechanically the way the math works
that's why I keep ranting about it you
pick a point
you generate the data that's like
assigning the likelihood score you wrote
when you wrote the generative model you
told me how likely it was right that
given you were in a in a in a in a
particular cluster that you would
generate this point that's the normal
distribution and then you compare it and
bake them off against each other and
that gave you a probability distribution
that's it awesome
now
there's the other step
this step is much less interesting
so here we're given all those wijs
J which is our current estimate
test
of p z i
equals J
okay
for I goes from 1 to n j goes from 1 to
K
okay
and what we have to do is estimate the
observed parameters
the non-latent parameters
now this is conceptually interesting
because
right we split our thing into latent
which are not observed the zi's are not
observed how what the probability is
that you're in a particular class and
the things we did observe the frequency
you know how many are in each class you
know their cluster sizes and all the
rest like you can measure those things
okay and we'll do that using mle because
that's the tool we use
by the way we use mle a lot in this
course
um but they're it's not it's very
powerful but it's not everything and
come back to that later
but that's it's a principle okay so for
example what is 5j what is the estimated
frequency well
we sum over all the points I goes from 1
to n of w j i this is a there are gas of
the fraction of elements
and from cluster J we can we can make
this a little bit more rigorous and
we'll do it next time and the point is
is you just do mle I don't want to go
through these calculations because
they're kind of boring
um
but we should you should go through them
at least once
and we can make that rigorous and we'll
do that when we do the mle thing so I'll
do it in class so don't worry if it
doesn't stick now we'll do it on Monday
in a little bit more generalized setting
but what I hope you get here is if I
know the wijs I have to compute the
estimate of 5j and then I just average
over the probabilities and we'll make
that we'll do all the math to expand
that out but you already know how to do
this this is just the mle stuff that
you've been doing for the last K weeks
okay
so far so good
no we're going to uh we're not going to
be we're the this is the the right
answer we're going to derive this in
more generality so you can solve for a
larger class of models on Monday
oh fractional points sorry that's really
terrible I said elements and then I
don't know why these are the points
points
from this should be sourced I kept using
I was trying to make source and Target
in independent my head and I did not use
them carefully in these lecture
apologies product points from first gen
is the rough intuition of why this is
okay means kind of this similar to you
you pick a set of means which are like
your sufficient statistics to describe
your problem then you re-average over
them and what's going on here is you're
picking a set uh now instead of just
picking centers you're picking
distributions then what you're doing is
you're re-weighting the distribution
saying if that was really the background
probability of all these linkages then
this is what your most likely cluster
sizes would be this is how what you know
how much points you would have in each
okay does that agree with your guess and
you just cycle that again and again
until you get back to the guest the same
way you're doing okay means
awesome
all right
so yeah
uh uh a bunch yeah a bunch Yeah so
basically an em model can be applied
whenever you have a latent uh Z like
this and you want to do some kind of
decomposition to it
yeah it's going to have this this
two-step pattern uh where you have an uh
latent variable and then I mean it's not
neces like there's no requirement that
any of this be supervised in some sense
the latent variable is like your guess
at supervision we'll see ways to inform
uh so for example we'll see an algorithm
where the first way it was derived
actually did use em but there's a more
clever way to solve it provably but em
is the general form of like there's a
latent variable that you don't see and
you have a model for it you estimate
that parameter and then you solve like a
traditional supervised machine learning
or
um kind of estimation problem under the
covers yeah and that's very very general
your latent variable here is clusters
but we'll see it could be you know
distributions and all kinds of fancy
stuff later
please students
at least
initial class or for example kilometers
so no so oh great question I see where
the confusion comes in no so here it's
like we are almost memoryless so we had
those you know Phi and and sigma and all
those other things and now just like in
k-means we throw away some information
and we try to reconstruct it and here
given our link of pis we try to compute
all of those observed parameters which
are going to be the mues and the sigmas
and the phi's and blah blah blah the
rest of the observed parameters so it's
like given the linkage function we do
that again and then what we would expect
is that those parameters will not move
around so much over time and that's when
it will converge similar to the way K
means word great great question
yeah yeah uh there there is nothing that
has such a crisp solution to my
knowledge I don't actually know one but
that's a that's a really good question
how do you initialize this and and what
situations can you can you better
initialize it um it seems natural enough
to think about one but I don't know a
proof for one yeah it's a great question
you can post it on Ed and I can dig
around and see if anyone did that my
suspicion is yes because K means plus
plus was such a important thing
it's a wonderful idea
other questions
all right okay
so
looking at this trying to think what I
should tell you
um
all right so we have about nine minutes
left
let me see all right so what I'm gonna
what I want to do is I think I want to I
want to just tell you the steps that
we're going to go through next time
because I think over the weekend this
will be too much traditionally I teach
it Monday Wednesday but I'm going to
want to redo this I think that's what I
think so right now what I want to do is
uh have a detour into one thing that we
need which is convexity and Jensen's
inequality
so I'm just going to draw the basics
here
and then I'll give you a sense of what
the EM algorithm looks like now the
reason we need this is that this is a
key result
and it confuses people every year so I
spend more time on it and hopefully it
confuses them last sometimes people say
it's trivial and then I'm very very
happy so if you think it's trivial then
I did my job okay all right
so what we're going to need to do the
reason I want to tell you this is what
we're going to have to do is we're going
to have to have a mathematical
abstraction of like this going back and
forth and is guessing back and forth and
that's going to be basically two
different functions one function is
going to be a lower bound of the
function there's going to be the actual
loss function for the totally you know
crazy probability distribution that has
all the infinite models and everything
jointly together okay the actual
likelihood function and what we're going
to do is we're going to have an
approximation of it that says given we
have a particular guess of the zi's
we're going to have this lower bound and
we're going to have to move between the
lower bound and the upper bound and that
and the lower bounding function and that
is going to be facilitated by something
called Jensen's inequality and it's
worth understanding because it's
something that you can use so I'll just
get started a little bit on it and draw
some pictures and then we'll we'll pick
it up next time
okay
a b element of Omega and I would
certainly rather answer questions
because you know we can cut into later
lectures so don't we don't need to rush
okay
a b is n Omega okay so let me draw this
okay so something is convex
if the line joining them oops
is inside
them okay so like if I take any two
points in here any A and B and I draw
the straight line between them or
euclidean space so it's a straight line
then if it's convex then no matter which
points I pick the line between them is
going to remain in the set this is a
convex object so like an ellipse or a
circle or something like that
in contrast here
if I pick points A and B here
this is not convex
okay
and these These are going to be you know
um
yeah we're going to care about these
quite a bit okay so what does this mean
in symbols and symbols
we have to check
for all Alpha for all a b and Omega
which is our set Omega
Lambda a plus one minus oops
1 minus Lambda B that's the line between
them
is an element of Omega
and Lambda here is an element of 0 1.
okay that's all this picture is saying
this picture in this math are the same
okay and you need to check for all right
right here clearly if I put a here and B
here there's a line between them the
reason it's not convex is there exists
one pair of A and B for which I I go out
of this set okay now we're going to use
it when this bottom piece is a function
right we think about the function going
up to Infinity the graph of the function
mean convex and what this tells us is
when we if we look at chords that is
points between the function like this
they should always be lower bounds to
the function and that will be a little
bit opaque but it'll feel like you think
about a function that looks like this
the x squared function
the that set will be convex that's the
canonical convex function okay all right
so
what we're going to see is we're going
to go from these definitions of
convexity on sets to convexity on
functions and that's going to allow us
to basically prove the following
statement which we will prove next time
which looks mysterious
but is not you'll see this
is greater than F of e of x
okay so there's going to be we're going
to show next time just I want to I want
to you know give a little bit of a road
map we're going to use this definition
of convexity to prove a theorem this
theorem is called Jensen's theorem and
it's effectively immediate from the
definition
like once you understand the definition
of this for functions if f is convex
this is true F convex
a function is convex if it's graphis
convex we'll draw that out okay
once we know that
we're going to need that for convex and
concave functions that's going to be a
key building block for what we do for
the next couple of lectures we've talked
about convexity once or twice in the
supervised setting
um
but now we're going to need it in a
little bit more detail okay all right so
let me wrap up and tell you what we did
today so that you remember what I want
you to take away so we started with this
idea of the difference between
supervised and unsupervised learning we
then went through k-means which was a
really simple heuristic algorithm but
you know in a hard problem that would
find these clusters we talked about this
idea that you needed to be able to model
the problem to be able to solve it you
had to input either K or something and
you had to be able to check or at least
visually inspect the answer
we then talked about a generalization of
k-mean what's called mixture of
gaussians and the only generalization
was rather than belonging to a single
cluster deterministically you tried to
find this probability distribution over
everything
that led to a bunch of notation but the
notation still basically had this
two-step procedure underneath the cover
of Guess The Centers and then check How
likely they are the How likely they are
and K means was the distance in GMM it
had this more complicated probabilistic
model we like that more complicated
probabilistic model because it's going
to allow us to model even more
sophisticated Notions of structure and
then I think I'm just going to go
through that on Wednesday so that you
have all the mathematical details there
together and we'll we'll do a review of
that thanks so much for your time and
attention have a great day